ma porca di quella eva sveglia che ci
sono le gocce la amo questa cosa tutti
ragazzi è ben evidente mi sono familiari
siamo su drive box e non che mi gasa
troppo dire sono è bellissimo siccome vi
è piaciuto tantissimo
ti sei fatto male zio siccome mi era
piaciuto così tanto faccio qualche altro
episodio perché io vado pazzo di drago
quali generale quindi meglio così ok
vede un inferno è una che contro maroni
se riesco la prima sera due caccia dove
got heynckes che voglio voglio
assolutamente nella vita gotte in chami
piano che figo il grido di guerra e la
faccia contro 11 fortissimo che mi fa il
culo a casa voglio morire ecco gli oil a
distruggersi ragazzi ho perso già nella
scelta della mappa prova che scegliamo
lo stesso il cielo cioè della serie
gothic se il dio della distruzione
contro easyjet ci siano ragazzi io
voglio fare il culo attacco e chiasso
già partendo bene non ci credo la prima
volta nella mia vita guarda non mi fai
culo guardo come ecco sono mosso un
braccio e ho fatto il culo ragazzi sto
imparando a giocare a quella di provare
a fare sta roba beh non è che queste su
c'è chi ha colpito chicca non ho capito
un cazzo e allora io di fare la cosa va
a fa ancora minchia che come come ho
fatto a forza 9 12 o mai più nella vita
ruli doppiezze terminati o no
cazzo non mi ha preso che culo quando la
mia è leggermente mancato niente ragazzi
sto di è sta diventando troppo forte non
c'è ma come faccio forse è poi muoio io
come terminato super sayan veloce cazzo
vai così mi cosa troppo forse cose ma è
così le botte in faccia forza cous cous
ho fatto o porca [__] ma veramente
effetto ce l'ho l'ho presa nel culo
subito dopo ma ok ho vomitato dei
fantasmini ma per cosa cioè me la
ricordo st mossa di gotham se non hai
capito un cazzo praticamento da farmi
fare un attimo tracollo e meteorite
veloce bello è servito no magari se
gliela fa in faccia è meglio non so è
grazie no no no no no no no no no
ragazzi siamo quasi alla fine e siamo
quasi alla stessa vita ho preso dai
cazzo veloce o non ci credo mia casa e
facendo me lo stai mettendo nel cap
ranzi e all'ultimo sangue proprio non
posso perdere un posto no non ci credo
non mi incazzo giuro che mi incazzo cosa
fai
sì sì sì no no no no no no non osi
[__] [__] vaffan cuore sono morto
pandaj minchia tragga non ci credo non
ci voglio credere
vi prego ditemi che non è vero sono
fatto perdere da uomo li voglio la rivi
me ne fotto il cazzo me ne sbatto i
[__] altamente finché non la vinco
me ne frega niente proprio dai ma perché
si sa mica bravo cazzo bravo bello mi
hai preso tre volte mi hai preso
i casi cose veloce veloce loach è
bravissimo finito per sente già come
meagan giorni volta
bye bye bye bye combo combo combo su
kong e ragazzi le colle come le sto
facendo a caso sperando che funzionino
perché andata non so come cazzo
il bello è che lui sta fermo ma cosa
cazzo stai fermo e essendo fermo riesce
a guardaroba sentiti o fai poco il figo
che non sei un modello di abercrombie tp
a calci in faccia di quella madonna o
miei primi anche lui sta fermo luisa
fermo cui doppiezze
[__] è non è possibile che possa
fermo sempre si basa troppo sto stronzo
stavolta li sto facendo un culo da come
ho fatto fare prima questo io non so che
cosa hai mangiato a pranzo zio ma porca
vacca cos'è sta roba stato colma
lanciato il sole praticamente mai così
sparagli sti cazzo di fantasmini però
spara li grande ha funzionato ci credo
ho praticamente vinto dai cazzo manca
niente tacco da emettere madonna che mi
metti negli occhiali zio per l'amor di
dio guai roba perché roba mi voglio
sempre a scott vieni qua venica venica
venica venica tempo scaduto ho vinto io
ho vinto io so che cosa faccia il si
prende a calci da sola riga ho vinto io
ragazzi va bene così è troppo forte e
troppo
passiamo alla prossima chi è meglio con
4 e troppo figo maledizione ragazzi
voglio assolutamente provare lui e belli
e un figlio e mi sa troppo di uomo
barbuto subisci un cazzo se sapevo che
c'era prima doccia anche gadget a dio
mio la partita che perderemo tutta la
vita ragazze dove lo scenario più po
apocalittico qua da mac distrutto mice
che bomba ragazzi io e la mia barba vi
faremo il culo ecco guardali come come
contenti
gillet il meglio di un uomo per farsi la
barba ragazzi incredibile alla ragazzi
concetta e mio personaggio preferito in
assoluto il problema è che ci farà il
culo a strisce ecco e vabbè dai cazzo ce
la farò colpirli una volta sola se sei
un cazzo sono morti niente reami stanno
facendo il culo o guardano ora con la
mette nel culo bravo così grande caso
cosa sto facendo non va bè impatto
gravitazionale cos'è mio dio per la
genchi da ma posso veramente fare genchi
dama ma sii serio e va beh se mi sembra
metti nel deretano di tre secondi
vabbè raga ma è impossibile batterla il
boss finale di dragon ball questo come
faccio a batterla c'è butta via
cos'ha fatto cose a ca nun so neanch'io
come ho fatto vice grande cazzo super
sayan no vabbè mi sono caricato troppo
madonna adesso ti faccio un culo viola
proprio medico me son forte può fare la
sfera genchi da masseria cazzo
la sta facendo sul serio ma come ma
veramente quanto gli ho tolto è quanto
mi ha tolto anche lui ragazzi ci stiamo
facendo un culo atroce fatto
gravitazionale vabbè la chiamano
[__] tutti ma posso rinascere se
sono a terra
sì sì posso dire meno male ma mi fai
riprendere bastardo niente mai neanche
mi fa riprendere subito
dov'è il fair play dove cazzo sapeva i
corvi sulle rocce
io mi carico voi fatti i cazzi vostri
dove shaun lurido stronzo vieni qua
bastarda eccolo che ho fatto prima
sì l'ho ucciso cazzo se devi morire tre
volte munire tre volte bastardo di gusto
esplosivo anche questa forza madonna me
ne vado
me ne sto andando dalla pro ag né
barriere ma chi sono
abbiamo vinto noi a caso alla battuta io
due non fatti fu 2 2 scritto due ko dove
obama con le medaglie dove cazzo è
veramente ciò c'è una soddisfazione in
corpo come se avessi battuto io comunque
con questi muscoli ragazzi sto gioco
casa di bruno perché gli avi conto sia
figo cazzo voglio vedere se riesco a
ricreare la battaglia tra goku e sel era
è la mia preferita è quella che mi piace
di più se l è sempre stato il mio nemico
preferito in assoluto quindi voglio
vedere che cazzo e ragazzi credo di
avere in questo preciso momento in mano
la soddisfazione di tutti voi quindi se
perdo ragazzi dover pagare la punizione
che ti può fare un blog in mutande si
madonna goku regala missa cosa che non
voglio fare blog in mutande mai così fa
torna il culo che gli sto facendo il
culo il culo il culo camera blog spara
glielo in faccia grande non l'ho presa
[__] [__] blanc ci riesco dai
oh mio dio non abbiamo fatto ho fatto la
mossa del secolo rega togliti dai campi
come si fa a sbattere fuori da persone
allora io non so come mi sto tele
trasportando ragazzi ve lo dico non ne
ho la piu pallida pro lo sto facendo
caio ken cazzo tipico no no no no per mi
fai sbagli culo fallico veloce tagli
ottenne fantastico no non ci posso
credere lurido pezzo di merda se non
avessi assorbito quel pirla di junior
non ce l'avresti st mossa ragazzi sto
perdendo merda non ci posso credere è
però veloce sì sì cazzo se vai di manca
pochissimo come faccio
[Musica]
cazzo si grande goku madonna quanto ti
amo quanto quanto ti amo
stavo sudando freddo perché avevo paura
di dover fare il blogging mutande e
triste molto triste quando sono stato tu
sto sudando veramente madonna che è
ricorsa non bambino quando gioca sta
roba che ci devo fare mi diverte fai un
saluto per salutare tutti zio bravo
eccolo lì grandissimo è un figo che ci
dobbiamo farlo ragazzine che posso
conclude qui vi dove sento seguito
perché giocavo mi piace anche a precari
facebook e come noi video trovate né
descrizione sono stati destinati nei
cibi di euro proseguito bella ragazza